So the last little piece to talk about
is the explore or exploit lemma.
So the idea of the explore or
exploit lemma is it gives us
the peace of the argument that we did
when we were doing deterministic Rmax,
which basically said if we are in
some kind of a loop going around and
around and around, and
we're getting optimal reward.
If not, then we're going to quickly
reach an unknown state, and
we're going to learn something.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And so
the corresponding version of
this in a stochastic domain.
Let's say we're running Rmax,
ad all the transitions are either
accurately estimated or
we mark them as unknown, and
we have it in our Rmax transition for
those state action pairs.
Then if we take that MDP and
optimize it, that optimal
policy is either near optimal.
In other words,
we're not making any mistakes.
The reward that we're getting as we
travel along this optimal policy is
essentially optimal, or we're actually
going to make it to some unknown state.
So Rmax is marked state, relatively
quickly in polynomial number of steps.
We're going to reach this new state,
and we're going to learn
something from that.
And so this property ends up being
true throughout the execution of Rmax.
>> I'm sorry, literally that property or
that property like
with high probability.
>> Right, with high probability, right.
So things can always fail.
We set up our union bound in
such a way to make sure that
the probability of failure
is sufficiently small.
Given that it hasn't failed,
then this will actually be true.
And if it's true, then what's going to
be happening is we're either going to be
doing the right thing, or we're going to
quickly bump into a new state and
learn something new and continue.
And the number of times that
we can learn something new is
going to be bounded by the number of
states times the number of actions.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And the number of steps before
we learn something new is bounded
by a polynomial in
the various quantities.
And that's, I think, all we need, right?
So we can't actually run for
a very long time without either learning
something new or being near optimal.
>> Huh.
I feel like there's some metaphor for
life here.
>> Hm.
How would that go?
>> I'm not sure something
about grad school.
>> Yeah you can't always just go there.
>> I'm pretty sure you can and
I proved it for many years.
>> Well I don't know if this is related
to grad school but it is sort of a key
property of these algorithms that's just
basically trying to handle the case that
says by virtue of the fact that we
make the unknown stuff optimistic.
We do the right thing right?
So we're either learning quickly or
we're being near optimal.
And so what would be bad is if there was
some kind of hole in between these two
cases that says, well we're kind of
stuck doing something sub optimal for
a long time, but we don't know it and
we don't learn that we
are doing something wrong.
That's the bad case.
And what this lemma is
about is showing that,
in fact,
the bad case doesn't happen there.
Either we're learning something or
we're doing very well.
>> Right.
And that could only not happen if we
were incredibly and extremely unlucky.
But if we were incredibly and
extremely unlucky,
then you couldn't learn anything anyway.
>> Yeah.
Right, well,
that's back to this sort of PAC notion
that it's probably going to work.
[LAUGH] And we can actually put-
>> At least approximately.
>> Yeah, that's right.
And working is here
related to approximately.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So
that was really all I wanted to get
at with exploring explorations.
This idea that even in general MDP's we
have a way of organizing our learning so
that we can make guarantees on
how close to optimal we are and
how quickly we get there.
>> But wait a minute,
you didn't tell me what C was.
Is C just quickly?
>> Oh, this C is correct.
>> No I meant the original
C that was a parameter.
>> Oh, well I did not write
down a formula for that.
But it follows the same analysis as what
we did when we wrote down the value of C
for bandits.
>> Oh, okay.
>> So, good enough?
We could make that a homework problem.
>> Sure.
I mean that's what we usually do.
[LAUGH] I want to write something down.
[LAUGH] Okay.
>> All right, done.